die bundesverfassung hat in den letzten
tagen und wochen gezeigt dass sie
eigentlich für alle eventualitäten
grundlegende demokratische spielregeln
vorgeben
um diese grundlegend demokratischen
spielregeln feiern den einhundertsten
geburtstag
aus diesem anlass macht die
wanderausstellung des
verfassungsgerichtshofs zu diesem
jubiläum in der maria theresien kaserne
in wien halt die möglichkeit bis dato
schon vielen dingen ganz österreich auf
eine niederschwellige art und weise
unsere bundesverfassung der das 100
jährige jubiläum gefeiert hat auch
dementsprechend kennenzulernen
das ist schon sehr perfekt gelungen das
interesse der menschen an der verfassung
ist durch diverse aussagen des
bundespräsidenten spürbar größer
geworden
ich glaube dass das bewusstsein dafür
gestiegen ist und steigt das bewusstsein
für verfassung steigt immer in
krisenzeiten und wir erleben in den
letzten fünf jahren verschiedene krisen
bewährungsproben und wir erleben aber
auch dass sich die verfassung und die
demokratie bewährt haben auch die
tätigkeiten des verfassungsgerichtshofs
sind zunehmend in den mittelpunkt
gerückt die tätigkeit des
verfassungsgerichtshofes ist mehr an die
öffentlichkeit gerückt und dadurch ist
auch genauer hingeschaut worden ob wir
unsere arbeit ordentlich und gut machen
und ich denke wir haben den beweis
erbracht dass wir auch in schwierigen
zeiten unsere aufgabe dem geister
verfassung nach einer für ihn keiner
wenn sie diese wanderausstellung 100
jahre verfassung durch ganz österreich
hat ist klar definiert wir wollen die
inhalte der verfassung die werte die der
verfassung zu grunde liegen
den menschen in unserem land näher
bringen demokratie rechtsstaatlichkeit
und menschenrechte
man kann nicht mehr davon ausgehen dass
jeder auch die grundbegriffe der
verfassung kennt und im alltäglichen
leben nimmt man die dinge so
selbstverständlich hin und daher halte
ich es wirklich sehr wichtig dass wir
diese möglichkeit hier an dieser stelle
anbieten und auch wenn wir bestimmte
situationen in der zweiten republik noch
nicht hatten
so ist doch in unserer in unserer
bundesverfassung vorsorge getroffen für
alle diese eventualitäten die uns mit
denen wir überraschend konfrontiert sein
können